hi I'm Rory near al from the Chennai hub
I'm a global shaper and this is my first
time at a World Economic Forum event and
I I must say it's been an amazing
amazing experience I've got to meet so
many different people and been a part of
many amazing sessions and one of the
sessions I really enjoyed being a part
of was the private session on healthy
living I'm a medical student and you
know this was definitely an area for me
to contact with the Medical Council of
India and you know different policy
makers so it was a great opportunity for
me i'm also an Olympic campaigner and
the sport of sailing so it was great as
you know to be a sports person and have
my point of view or being put across and
I like to congratulate the weapon
calling such an amazing forum and I look
forward to being you know invited to a
lot more